what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts
Hassan Minaj has been all over the news
this week after a story published in the
New Yorker went viral claiming the
comedian has been blatantly lying and
completely fabricating details of his
life including many of the stories in
his 2022 Netflix special the king's
Jester you might be thinking to yourself
but doesn't every comedian bend the
truth and make stuff up for the sake of
their jokes why is this any different
well in the case of Hassan Minaj it's a
bit more complicated than that Hassan
wasn't lying for the sake of humor he
was telling boldface lies on stage not
to make people laugh but in an effort to
drive political narratives evoke
sympathy and pity towards himself and
create a fake sense of victimhood and
paranoia all for personal gain in this
video we're going to be taking a look at
this entire story from start to finish
but before we do that let's listen to
the jokes and questions straight from
Hassan's mouth starting off with the
attack on his daughter
he hands them to me I rip it open I flip
it over and all this white powder
falls into the stroller
and it falls on my daughter's shoulder
her neck her Cheeks
is she staring at me
and I run upstairs and I tell BINA
and this time I can't lie
we rushed down to NYU
but this time we go through the
emergency room
and the moment they see the baby they
just rip the clothes off her and they
take her away
and me and Bina were sitting in the
waiting room for hours and we're not
talking
finally around midnight nurse comes in
and she's holding my daughter
but she's with an investigator
and the investigator reaches into his
pocket
and he pulls out a plastic baggie
filled with white powder
because Mr minhaj
you're very lucky
it real anthrax
but I've been in this department long
enough to know this [__] just doesn't
come out of nowhere
so I have to ask you something young man
Earth
have you been antagonizing
[Music]
everybody
do you have to do that
I'm like I don't know
I don't know why I'm doing this
they give the baby back to Beni and I
reach over to hold my daughter
won't let me touch her
and it kills me
we get home she puts the baby down then
she finally talks to me she goes okay
we're going to talk about this once then
we're never going to talk about it ever
again
why we're here tonight foreign
is because you chose clout
over our kids
Michael kits
did you say kids
she goes I'm pregnant
I like the sequel according to the
article published by the New Yorker
September 5th 2023 the New York Police
Department which investigates incidents
of possible bacillus anthracis has no
record of an incident like the one Minaj
describes nor do area hospitals front
desk and Mail Room employees at
menajah's former residence don't
remember such an incident nor do
employees involved with the show's
security or menage's security guard from
the time during our conversation Minaj
admitted that his daughter had never
been exposed to a white powder and that
she had not been hospitalized by the way
he's making up a story and the heir of
it is that like it's just like I go
there I go so over the line even Time
Magazine is like whoa you're crazy and
it's like by the way my whole family's
like can you just not
there for once meanwhile
never takes it there by the way he just
says the easiest he just does like a
Trump's an orange Goblin yeah like his
whole thing is just like you know what
I'm gonna say something Trump's racist
and like that's his kind so it's like
yeah you don't act like you take it
there the article goes on to explain
another joke from the same special where
Hassan tells a detailed story from his
youth about an undercover FBI agent who
infiltrated his local Sacramento mosque
back in 2002 in the Netflix special
Hassan claims this FBI agent was
islamophobic and arrested Hassan for no
reason even slamming his head onto the
hood of a police car the author of the
article was able to track down the FBI
agent in question and when asked about
these stories he said menajah's story is
a complete fabrication I have no idea
why he would do that in fact montilia
was in prison in 2002 and didn't begin
to work for the FBI until 2006.
additionally he only worked in Southern
California not the Sacramento area where
Hassan claims these events took place
wait by Andrew yes comedians make up
stories all the time that's true now
usually we do it to make things funnier
not make things more racist sad or
emotional yeah and I think that's the
tricky thing here in his stories it's
not like he was using these
exaggerations or hyperboles punch lines
he was using them to kind of make the
audience feel worse about him and then
it turns out these things didn't
actually happen when discussing all of
this it is important to point out that
comedians making up stories or
exaggerating certain situations for the
purpose of entertaining Their audience
is part of their job description when
the story first broke there was a crowd
of people in support of Assam who were
all quick to point out other jokes
famous comedians have told on stage that
included clearly fabricated details
including Dave Chappelle's famous baby
in the hood bit the funny thing about
this argument is that it kind of proves
why what Hassan did was wrong in no way
shape or form is it clear that any of
his stories are made up if anything he's
trying to convince everyone listening to
accept them as fact which is the
complete opposite of what someone like
Dave Chappelle is trying to do with an
outlandish impossible premise just
listen to Chappelle's Joe about a baby
selling drugs in the hood and compare it
to the tone of Hassan's Anthrax joke
that we heard earlier that is when I
know I was in a bad neighborhood you
only see this in the worst neighborhoods
remember it's three o'clock in the
morning it's three o'clock in the
morning
I look out the window
it was a baby standing on a corner
and the baby the baby didn't even look
scared he was standing
I mean it made me sad to make me say it
really good you know because I want to
help the baby
I don't trust you either I'm sorry quit
the old baby on the corner trick eh
not gonna fall for that [__]
[Applause]
where's this limousine driver you know I
stopped feeling bad
as time goes by I start feeling worse
like man what is wrong with me what the
hell is wrong I'm scared of a baby
in trouble he might need my help I gotta
do something
but I wasn't gonna get out the car
I'm serious man I just cracked the
window a little bit
I mean I can roll it down
foreign
[Applause]
see the difference the only thing Dave
Chappelle gained for making up that
story was laughs Hassan Minaj is using
his platform as a comedian which allows
you the option to slightly bend the
truth to create scenarios out of thin
air that drive a narrative and create
division amongst people all while
casting himself as the victim and using
that victimhood as currency to move up
in his profession this is a lot
different than embellishing a punchline
lies that purposely create divide in
society going out of his way to prop up
racism and paranoia to millions of
people these stories coming from Hassan
skew people's outlook on reality in a
negative way Chappelle might be lying
but he's lying to make you laugh Hassan
is lying for personal gain without even
being funny the theme was heartbreak so
for years doing stand-up and I get the
topic of heartbreak so I had to think
about what was my first time falling in
love and who was the first person that I
fell in love with you're given the topic
and then you have to figure out a story
so it was kind of the first time that I
had to let go of the act and then just
go all right I just have to tell a real
story and maybe they'll be funny moments
within it told the story about the first
person that I loved and trying to go to
prom with her and then not being able to
go because of her parents and
um Catherine Burns uh the creative
director of The Moth was like that's a
[__] like what ended up happening with
you and your dad and sneaking out to try
to go to prom and then experiencing this
on the doorstep not being able to go
because the color of your skin and what
happened with her parents I started to
slowly sort of write it out yeah he made
life worse for other people in real life
oh wait how is that have you you know
the prom story right what's the prom
story prom Story the homecoming King is
based on this story that he was supposed
to go to prom with a white girl got to
the door she's putting a corsage on
another a guy a white guy oh yes her
parents didn't like the fact that Husson
was Indian and that's a terrible
terrible story yeah lady responds I know
what I picked and said
he responds and it's like not only is
this not true he asked me days before
the prom I just said no and not only are
my parents not racist I'm married to an
Indian let go of the ACT I just have to
tell a real story in the weeks following
the article being published in the New
Yorker Hassan addressed the criticism
defending himself and pushing back on
the idea that what he did was wrong in
any way saying quote my comedy Arnold
Palmer is 70 emotional truth and 30
percent hyperbole exaggeration fiction
even his response doesn't make that much
sense because his arguable none of this
was done for the sake of Comedy or jokes
these lies weren't really to make people
laugh they were completely self-serving
with the purpose of garnering sympathy
from an audience we've seen comedians
get busted for massive lives in the past
with the most famous example being Steve
ranazizi falsely claiming to be a 911
Survivor for many years but even in that
most egregious of examples Steve's lie
never made it on stage or into a joke
and it wasn't necessarily used to
benefit his career Hassan on the other
hand was basically taking part in
mainstream media fear-mongering but
through comedy and Netflix instead of
fox and CNN I also understand there's
some people who don't think this is a
very big deal and understand that lying
is a part of Comedy I'm very curious to
hear what you guys think about this
entire situation so please sound off in
the comments down below our boy Hassan
Minaj uh minhaj minhaj I think yeah how
do we even know how do we even know that
that's how he pronounces we get to
decide what the truth is I think I think
that his name is 70 emotionally true and
then guest spots from last week The Joe
Rogan Experience had on Kurt Angle and
Francis naganu two bears one cave was
Burton Tom and Bert kiltony this week
was a massive and Chaotic episode with
Shane Gillis Mark Norman Ari shaffir Ric
Flair Louis J Gomez and zakamiko ymh did
not have a guest we might be drunk out
on Rick Glassman Matt and Shane's secret
podcast had Rich Voss on the program
Shane also made an appearance on the Pat
McAfee show are you garbage had on Ari
shaffir Jared freed was on the Honeydew
taste buds head on the ru garbage boys
to battle Hot Pockets versus Elio US
Pizza Dane Cook was the guest on Whiskey
Ginger flagrant did not have a guest and
Andrew Santino was the guest on Chrissy
chaos do you think that me being an only
child is weird and do you think that
people who are only children are weird
and just kind of like we were grown we
were brought up and like we're selfish
and we're not good people yeah you do I
agree with you only kids are are I was
an only kid for owned by the way older
kids is a new service coming out that's
[__] amazing who runs at the clinic
yes it's called only kids get your kids
on it I mean it's really a Big Money
Maker only kids only kids
presented by the clintons could you
imagine this stuff's great this stuff's
great that's that's the slogan this
stuff's great this is great considered
the episode of the week by many this
past weekend with Theo Von had on Bobby
Lee the Tim Dylan show was a solo
episode Zachary Levy was on first date
take your shoes off head on Sarah
Kubrick Rich Voss and bad brain were on
you know what dude tiger belly had on
Chrissy D Matt mccusker and Mike Racine
were both on being Ian with Jordan samj
went on stavy's world and Mark Schiff
was on the Harland Highway as far as new
stand-up specials are either out right
now or coming out soon Michelle wolf has
a new three-part series out right now on
Netflix called it's great to be here
which is done in a very unique way not
like traditional specials we also have
some new projects out on YouTube right
now one from Joe bartnick called a
killing in Chicago and one from Dan
Cummings titled trying to get better
that's the beauty of sports right it
doesn't actually matter who wins or
loses
right the the results are actually
pretty trivial right it's easy you don't
have to think much about it because it
doesn't matter you just go you root for
this jersey you Boo for that Jersey you
high-five this [__] you drink this
beer you have a great [__] time go
fight win and gas digital looks to be
rounding up their six-week run of weekly
specials over the past month or so
they've given us 30 minutes with Dave
Smith Kurt Metzger Lewis J Gomez Colin
Terrell and Jordan Jensen five fantastic
half hours of Comedy that all performed
very well on everyone's individual
channels they still have one more
performance yet to be released 30
minutes with Rich Voss they'll be out on
YouTube later today congrats to gas
digital you're producing a bunch of
[__] specials you got them cooking
yeah I'm pumped there were six of us
that did them we did six half hour
specials over the course of three nights
Dave Smith first Kurt Metzger's just
came out last week mine's out uh today
officially and then next week is Colin
turo sure Jordan Jensen and then Rich
Voss they're all incredible comedians
very different very different
perspectives it was really a great group
and I'm happy how they came out they
were [__] great there's also quite a
few specials that gonna be out
relatively soon Kim congdin is filming
her first career stand-up special
December 7th as well as Salvo Cano who's
planning on filming his first special in
Chicago December 1st and 2nd it's also
important to let everyone watching this
video know that joke world is officially
now on Twitter or X or whatever you want
to call it if you like us on YouTube if
you're a fan of this joke World YouTube
channel you'll definitely enjoy
interacting with our content on all
different platforms Instagram Twitter
Facebook our second channel here on
YouTube you name it thank you so much
for the support thank you so much for
watching this video please subscribe and
we'll be back next week with some more
videos oh also best of September coming
out October 1st October 2nd this week
later this week this is going on too
long thank you for watching
at
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out